Hi!
How are are you?
I'm so good. How are you?
I don't know why I felt compelled to say that
like we were at a boxing match.
I feel like I should get up
and have a sign with a sash
and round 15.
(audience laughing)
Gabriel "Fluffy" Iglesias!
You have no idea what you just did for me.
(Drew laughing)
You have such a large following.
People really like fall on the sword for your words,
and I love when people are
very beloved by kids and adults,
which is not an easy thing to do
and be able to be raw and funny and truthful.
And that is not an easy line to walk.
And yet you do.
It's that whole trying to be like Shrek
where it's like you're edgy enough for the parents
but still fun enough for the kids
but you're right there where you don't cross that line.
I always let the people know,
hey, I'm not here to offend,
I'm here to entertain, here to have a good time.
And if at the end of the show you feel good
and you'd like to invite other people
to come out to the shows next time
please do that for me.
You guys are my voice.
I'm not trying to ruffle feathers.
I'm trying to bring people together,
not separate people.
What do you think that means,
comedy in 2020
with everything that's happening in the world?
Not only is it hard to transcend the ages,
but this year in particular.
Are there rules,
are there do's and don'ts?
'Cause you're obviously very sensitive to that.
I am very sensitive to that.
My only rules have been for the shows
don't talk about politics, religion, or sports
and you should be okay.
(audience laughing)
The more you share stories about engaging with people
as opposed to pushing people away,
I think that warms up audiences
and people want to just have more of that.
I don't want you to leaving the show questioning your life
and what should I think and what should I believe.
I just want you leaving the show going
"Man, that was a good time.
"I can't wait to go get something to eat."
Let's learn to,
I know we can't really hug each other right now
'cause, you know, (clears throat) for obvious reasons,
but I mean we want to bring people together
and remind everyone
that this is a time to care about one another.
(audience applauding)
When the pandemic started you had been touring
and is it hard not to tour,
because I'm like you,
I want to be with people.
Luckily I'm with this awesome team
that I work with every day
and we're so happy to be together.
But that must be hard if you're a people person
or a bringer togetherer.
Yeah, we were in the middle of the biggest tour I've had
and we were in Kalamazoo, Michigan.
And that was the day we got the,
we phone call,
I had a meeting on the tour bus and they said,
basically, they're pulling the plug after tonight
and we got to go home.
And it's like what?
And so,
I want to say that I had one of my best shows ever
'cause I knew that it was gonna be a while
before I touched the stage again.
Missing it as an understatement.
I was on a stage every single night.
And so to go from that to getting a lot of sleep
that I didn't know I needed (laughing).
But yeah, it was a shocker and a half for me
and I had to learn to readjust.
Yeah.
Is it true that you were almost a teacher?
I had the opportunity to become a teacher.
Almost means that that was like I was gonna make it happen
and then all of a sudden standup comedy
got in the way and took it over.
I took a course in high school called exploratory teaching,
and I didn't know that I was really good at it.
It was one of those things where
you get a grade for one thing
but being able to get in front of people and connect,
that's not something really that,
how do you teach that?
And they told me
that I had a gift for being in front of kids
and getting their attention.
And they said, "If you can get their attention
"you can teach them."
And obviously other things kind of got in the way
and that's why I'm here.
Well, thank goodness that they did.
And then you play a teacher on "Mr. Iglesias"
and that's so cool that you're a teacher in your job.
And the most amazing part
is that the school teacher who influenced me the most,
her name is June Garner
who was my speech teacher in high school,
and she's the one who would pushed me
and encourage me to enter speech tournaments,
and she says, "You're funny, you need to just get up there,"
and I really hated writing stuff down.
And she says, "Well just memorize your monologue,
"and I'll take you to the,"
she would drive me to these functions.
And
she was able to attend
all of the tapings of "Mr. Iglesias".
And I had thought that she had passed away a few years ago
because that's what they told me,
I'd lost touch with her.
And my buddy, Juan,
he found her and he brought her to the show
and I had no idea that she was there.
And so we reconnected
at the actual premiere of "Mr. Iglesias"
and we've been in touch since
Did you say "I'm so glad you're alive
"and I'm playing a teacher"?
(audience laughing)
She's a little more old school.
She was more like, you know,
"Blank-ity blank, blank blank.
"Who told you that I was dead?"
And I'm like, "Sorry and that wasn't me."
She sounds like my kind of lady.
Well my kids and I obviously love "Unleashed".
What an amazing show.
I--
-- right here, Drew.
Oh no.
Oh no, oh my goodness.
My dog Douglas has a tongue
that hangs out the side of his mouth too.
This is Risa, that's like Lisa with an R,
and she is 16 years old.
Oh, Risa.
See, I had my two dogs here,
but funny enough I had to send them home
because we have some visitors here on the set.
We're gonna take a quick break but when we come back
can we do some extraordinary animal acts with you?
I think we can.
(squealing) This is gonna be so fun.
(upbeat music)